Pulitzer prize-winning journalist Wesley
Lowery has extensively covered deadly
shootings by police officers and the
black lives matter movement Lowry is now
a correspondent for sixty and six lucky
for them which features 60-minute style
storytelling in six minute episodes it
premieres on the streaming app kwibi
this Sunday 60 in six is produced by CBS
News which is part of Viacom CBS which
by the way is investor in kwibi Larry
has been in Minneapolis covering the
death of George Floyd in the first
episode he speaks with Floyd's brother
and you've heard from some of these
families Eric Garner's mother's here
she's here loving mom I can tell she
remind me of my mother you know when I
was looking at her talking to her I was
hurt just sitting there talking to her I
didn't want to talk to her because I
knew her son passed wasting it I can't
breathe I can't breathe my brother
passed away the same way it won't there
nobody it's not right it's not right boy
Wesley Lowery joins us now from
Minneapolis Wesley Lowery it's so good
to see you may I just say your Atlantic
piece the breaking point is must must
must read I'm really glad to talk to you
today because you've been covering the
black lives movement matter for ten
years and unfortunately or maybe
fortunately you know the subject very
very well everybody keeps saying that
this is different does it feel different
to you with all that you know of course
well thanks so much for having me this
morning and what a heartbreaking clip
and that the whole interview with George
Floyd's brother was just the miserable
in the way you could feel and here is
pain about everything that was going on
this does feel different this moment
does feel different and I lay out in
this article that we publish at the
Atlantic yesterday and it's one of
things we talk about in the segments on
60 and 6-4 kwibi is that in this moment
you have what is just the latest in a
series of these videos we've seen so
many of them right going back years
Walter Scott Tamir rice volando Casteel
you know we all know the name Sandra
bland
and two different things were happening
black people were getting exhausted
watching these videos another one and
another one and another one and
meanwhile white Americans were saying
maybe this isn't just one bad police
officer maybe this isn't just one
isolated incident and so what we saw was
you had two different groups of people
reaching their breaking point
black Americans who were saying I can't
deal with this anymore and white
Americans who were saying we have to
deal with this we're in a moment right
now where it's clear when you walk to
these demonstrations right I've been
here in Minneapolis I was back home in
DC cover and protest for a bit
I've got colleagues across we all have
colleagues across the country when you
look at the people who are in the
streets it's a really diverse set of
folks in a way that's very different
than 20 14 and 15 and 16 because
everyone is like wait a second we got
them no one wants to watch another one
of these videos yeah and the young
people are talking to their parents too
in a way that I've never heard before
Wesley it does seem it's like the
perfect storm of pain it really does
feel like that what specifically did you
learn in Minneapolis while you were
there on the ground certainly I mean so
Minneapolis is a fascinating City
because Minneapolis is has been on the
front lines of this fight and this
movement as much as any other place
people forget that there was a police
shooting of a young black man named
Jamar Clark in 2015 and there was
massive protest here in Minneapolis as a
result of that you push forward an
earful and oh Casteel who's killed kind
of in suburban Minneapolis one of the
videos one of the shootings that
everyone knows about right and so this
isn't the first time this city has been
in the spotlight this isn't the first
time there's been activism in this city
but beyond that Minneapolis is a city
that has tried to do a lot of things
they've passed a lot of reforms they
have a black police chief whom many
people consider to be a great reformer
really really nice guy they elected a
wave of progressive leaders here and in
st. Paul and yet these shootings keep
continuing and these debts keep
continuing and so Minneapolis is kind of
a case study of doesn't need to be
bigger and more sweeping change or will
small reform but Wesley a question and
what the activists would say right now
is that needs to be more
let's say I hope you can answer and
answer this question quickly because you
were on a team that created a nationwide
police database of police officers what
was what are you hoping why did you do
that and how is it being used maybe just
answer how it's being used since we're
short on time course so the Washington
Post me and my colleagues we created a
database of every fatal police shooting
in the country we can go on if you
Google search right now Washington Post
police shootings you'll find every
shooting since January 1st 2015 the
federal government doesn't track this
data and so how do we have a
conversation about how to have fewer
police shootings if we don't even know
how many there are
right everyone wants to live in a world
where the police kill people including
the police and we got in order to make
that world all right I got to know how
often it happens and analyze those cases
all right Wesley Lowery thank you so
much for your time really looking
forward to seeing your piece I think
you're a terrific reporter thank you so
much